[Music]
no doubt you've seen the chaos in the
streets
we must make an example where France
will fall
what would you do if this assignment of
defense was transferred to you
[Applause]
I promise you probably had successes
[Music]
this is my uniform
I let the French Victory too long
what is your name Napoleon
the course of my life has changed
[Applause]
I'm destined for greatness
but those in power will only see me as a
sword
I suggest you take the throne as a king
shall we vote
this learning has held the world hostage
with his egotism and his lack of simple
good manners
I'm great
there is nothing without me
of Europe is the United forces against
me what's the outcome of this you don't
succeed
emergency we are discovered good
first to admit when I make a mistake
I simply never do
foreign